well I deeply regret these strikes and
in particular the timing which had been
timed at deliberately coming straight
after Easter the fact that the BMA
Junior doctors have asked their members
not to tell NHS managers whether they
intended to to go on strike or not
making contingency planning more
difficult and also their refusal to
agree any national exemptions other
health unions like the Royal College of
nurses agreed National exemptions
particularly for example for cancer
patients so that those patients weren't
impacted the junior doctors committee
has refused any national exemptions and
obviously that puts patients at greater
risk but we're working very hard to
mitigate those impacts I had a call
again with NHS England yesterday looking
at the contingency measures in place and
I want to thank people across the NHS
particularly the Consultants the nurses
the many staff who are working today to
mitigate the impact of the strikes what
shorts can you give to hundreds of
thousands of people who are affected by
this who will be very worried about
their health can you give them the
restaurants that you're putting every
effort possible into resolving this
situation and trying to get around the
table and have a new talk with Junior
doctors well a huge amount of effort is
going in to mitigate the impact of the
strikes to ensure that emergency cover
is there the clear message to the public
is for those who need the NHS the NHS
will be there in terms of responding to
Urgent calls but to be mindful of the
demands that they place on the NHS but a
huge amount of effort has gone into the
contingency plan and the measures in
place given the effects of the strikes
but clearly they've been time to have an
impact on patients and I think that's
very regrettable